we are welcome to this video playing
five minute again you on the auto
pairing and I try this blonde steve
larson Terrell come again our results
are not bad I'm surprised how many
people really know let's see three is
the best move I mean this line is fairly
uncommon but people really know that see
three years i'm supposed to be there to
critical news okay let's uh let's play
straight forward just looking at the
gentle g to the g-tube on down the g
fall against the king yes sometimes with
really easy moves you can get the big
ataxia miss black sometimes happens and
wow
Queen age five isn't this bit ugly
something better you at Queen h5 looks
good now distribution g4g for the
checking the night and where does it go
a way that could also take H form now
that is probably nonsense so what does
he doing no yeah of course you can can
do this but this looks like an I'm in
good shape six Bishop d6 and the other
look to g8 this is a really easy really
easy attack
oh ok so now he cannot move the night
yes but if i take wait wait wait wait
wait if i take g2 yeah it's probably not
too convincing what if i play rook g8
just um getting another piece and the
attack this looks like a good move
probably on something like okay night eh
to us nonsense anyway i can just take it
yeah I'm not not sure what what is
playing now it looks like a big attack
and rach gia what I can take g2 I think
yeah I can and if we cannot play rock g1
what on earth is he playing yeah this is
kind of a kind of a model game for for
this line if everything works out
perfectly you get a big attack on the G
file
yeah that's a move I don't see a move
look to you all my designs yeah there's
no move I mean really now the doctor
said don't see anyone if I give he goes
here I just take here and this is this
is over look check no yeah just just
here is this bishop on d6 this is an
inmate and one funny point is that this
one is answered by rook takes check me
and this made yeah I had seen this your
and then there's no move if you cannot
protect you too what on earth are you
doing yeah the computer gives 95 as the
best move this yeah okay but this is
just two pieces and a great position you
still have the attacker going on here
something like this good the mate yeah
this is the kind of game you you hope to
hit to get with the Bronstein Lauzon
really not losing any kind of tempo
finding up on the G file yeah if you are
interested in a bit of an unconventional
interesting opening as plexus is a
pretty good line it's not bad at all
yeah thanks for watching